y
el presidente de ruso vladimir putin
acusa a occidente de querer llevar a su
país a un conflicto armado con ucrania
rompiendo el silencio de las últimas
semanas el líder del kremlin aseguró que
eeuu y la otan ignoraron sus demandas en
materia de seguridad para desescalar las
tensiones
al menos 22 personas murieron en quito
en la capital ecuatoriana cayó una
tempestad inédita que provocó un aluvión
después que su fuera sobrepasada la
capacidad de un embalse varios barrios
quedaron inundados de lodos y las
autoridades siguen buscando a 20
personas que están desaparecidas
la oms advierte que muchos países no han
alcanzado el pico de la ola de contagios
desatada por la variante omicron y
declaró preocupada por la relajación de
medidas entretanto el organismo alertó
los efectos nefastos para la salud y el
ambiente que generan decenas de miles de
toneladas de desechos generados durante
la pandemia
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle
el presidente ruso vladimir putin rompió
su silencio de las últimas seis semanas
respecto a las tensiones entre su país
con el vecino ucrania el líder del
kremlin acusó a occidente de querer
crear de manera deliberada un escenario
para llevar a un conflicto armado aunque
agregó que todavía es posible encontrar
un acuerdo por la vía del diálogo
consideró que eeuu y la otan ignoraron
las las principales peticiones de rusia
en materia de seguridad moscú había
exigido que la otan detenga su expansión
y rechace una eventual adhesión de
ucrania a la alianza y que retire su
armamento de los países de europa del
este escuchamos a vladimir putin
no vemos un reconocimiento genuino de
nuestras tres demandas clave impedir la
expansión de la otan cancelar el
despliegue de armas cerca de las
fronteras rusas y devolver las
instalaciones militares del bloque a sus
posiciones en
1997 cuando se firmó el acta fundacional
de rusia
recién y para analizar las tensiones
entre rusia y ucrania está con nosotros
richard downie él es un coronel retirado
del ejército de eeuu y analista militar
señor dawn y bienvenido a france 24
rusia y eeuu insisten en mantener
abierta la puerta del diálogo aunque
ambos se mantienen inamovibles en sus
posturas cuál será la reacción de
vladimir putin tras considerar que sus
preocupaciones en materia de seguridad
han sido ignoradas
buenas noches vale clara
yo diría que no sería correcto decir que
el oeste está ignorando las demandas de
putte es más preciso decir que el oeste
está rechazando sus demandas y eso es
bueno porque lo que estamos haciendo es
mostrar que no estamos débil si
estábamos aceptando esas demandas sería
una recompensa a putin por su ver es por
su agresión y eso podría permitir que
putin y rusia
echarán la culpa a la ampliación de nato
de la otan y eso no sería correcto
entonces no es decir que estamos
ignorando estamos rechazando
precisamente esas esas demandas y más
jefes de estados llegan a ucrania para
expresar apoyo y el país anuncia un
aumento de 100.000 tropas en tres años
se acaba el tiempo para una solución
negociada a esta crisis absolutamente
hay hay tiempo para eso porque la
iniciativa está en los manos de putin la
otan y el oeste no no va a hacer nada en
termos militares más hasta que rusia
invadió
hace una agresión dentro de ucrania
porque lo que vamos a hacer en lo este
hemos dicho que si rusia lanzará un
ataque a ucrania vamos a iniciar
sanciones
entonces
no es de esas sanciones y las otras
acciones que la otan tomada serían en
reacción a una inversión entonces hay
tiempo
para la negociación con rusia china y
estados unidos y europa han defendido la
autonomía de la otan para decidir cuáles
son sus miembros sin cerrarle la puerta
a ucrania que implicaría si este país
entra a la alianza militar
eso es una buena pregunta porque lo que
pasa es hay que recordar que putin lo
que es que me más es tener un país
exitoso especialmente uno que sea que
tiene un tengo un liderazgo elegido
democráticamente a lo largo de su
frontera porque eso es mal para el resto
de los países lo que él quiere lo que
putin quiere es una esfera de influencia
que quiere controlar
y la ucrania en los otros países a lo
largo de frontera con el oeste entonces
lo que nosotros tenemos que hacer es
mantener la posición porque si nosotros
aceptamos las concesiones o damos
concesiones a rusia vamos a hacer débil
y él va a pedir a aumentar sus demandas
para otras cosas bien señor dani gracias
por estas respuestas y en otras noticias
22 personas murieron en quito la capital
ecuatoriana consecuencia de un aluvión
que afectó el noroccidente de la ciudad
al menos 20 personas siguen
desaparecidas y 47 más resultaron
heridas las fuertes lluvias que han
azotado la capital del país hicieron que
se sobrepasará la capacidad de un
embalse en la quebrada el tejado
provocando el deslizamiento de lodo y
rocas en el sector conocido como la
gasca los vídeos de las redes sociales
mostraron un río lleno de lodo arrasando
árboles vehículos e incluso postes de
electricidad un sobreviviente describió
lo que pasó
pero yo estaba yendo a entrar al túnel y
cuando eso salió una avalancha solamente
veía algo café que era piedras lodo y
palos y uno que trata desde treparme a
la vereda para poder salvarme un poco y
que no me lleve leyendo la avalancha me
trepé a la vereda y al muro cuando en
eso pasó un poco de la avalancha pero el
resto ya me vino dando vuelta me hizo
pelear contra el muro de esta casa
rompimos el muro de esta casa de la
fuerza del agua lo que hizo me rebotó
para este lado pero por suerte gracias a
dios la mano de dios me cuida muy
vuestros dos guapos es que no me
permitieron que me siga arrastrando
porque si no hubiese sido peor
las muertes por kobe 19 están aumentando
en todo el mundo la alerta la dio la
organización mundial de la salud su
director pedrosa no me quebré jesús
rechazó las falsas afirmaciones de que
ya no es posible prevenir la transmisión
del virus y advirtió que todavía es
prematuro que los países comiencen a
cantar victoria sobre la pandemia
sankán crisis nos preocupa que en
algunos países se haya arraigado una
narrativa de que debido a las vacunas y
a la alta transmisibilidad y menor
gravedad de omicron ya no es posible ni
necesario prevenir la transmisión
más lejos de la verdad
nací en el werder from the truth
moore transmisiones por veces más
transmisión significan más muertes no
estamos pidiendo a ningún país que
regrese al llamado bloqueo pero estamos
pidiendo a todos los países que protejan
a su gente usando todas las herramientas
del conjunto de herramientas no sólo
vacunas es prematuro para cualquier país
rendirse o declarar victoria vaccines
habló
exprima your for any country leader
choose hérner por tula island big three
otra de las preocupaciones de la
organización mundial de la salud es el
incremento de los desechos sanitarios
durante la pandemia un nuevo informe del
organismo revela que la carga de
residuos aumentó diez veces y advierte
que el problema no sólo es por la
contaminación del aire y del agua sino
que desechos como jeringas o guantes
exponen a cientos de personas en el
mundo juan pabló lucumí nos explica
la batalla contra el hobbit 19 ha traído
una nueva amenaza para el medio ambiente
y la salud pública un informe de la
organización mundial de la salud señala
que decenas de miles de toneladas de
desechos de material médico que en algún
momento fueron utilizados para combatir
el coronavirus se acumulan en vertederos
y se convierten en un gran problema
descubrimos que el kobe 19 ha aumentado
la carga de residuos sanitarios en las
instalaciones hasta 10 veces los
volúmenes actuales y se considera que 2
de cada 3 instalaciones sanitarias en
los países menos desarrollados no tenían
un sistema para segregar o tratar de
forma segura los residuos el informe
señala que aproximadamente 87 mil
toneladas de equipos de protección
personal adquiridos entre marzo de 2020
y noviembre de 2021 terminarán en
desechos después de ser utilizados
además de contaminar el aire y el agua
de las comunidades que viven cerca de
los vertederos mal gestionados toneladas
de jeringas desechadas kits de pruebas
usados guantes y frascos de vacunas
exponen a múltiples riesgos a los
trabajadores sanitarios ante esto la
organización propone alguna soluciones
no utilizar guantes para la vacunación y
otras interacciones en las que los
guantes no sean necesarios utilizar
vidrio y otros envases más ecológicos y
aumentar el uso de artículos seguros
reutilizables en particular máscaras
seguras reutilizables para el público en
lugar de máscaras desechables el reporte
llega en un momento clave cuando el
sector sanitario enfrenta presiones para
reducir su huella de carbono y disminuir
la cantidad de desechos
hasta aquí las noticias esperen más en
minutos
[Música]